hey guys and we'll go back to lesson on
coding my name is Ryan lesson so in
today's video I will be showing you how
to build a very highly scalable project
set up with angular 4 and web pack so
I'll be showing you just some extra tips
and tricks I use personally in my
project setups to make it very highly
configurable and available in depth in
many different environments so I thought
any further ado let's get started
okay guys so to get started with our
project setup I'm gonna be starting this
thing pretty much from scratch so first
things first we're going to need to get
all of our dependencies we need for our
project so I was loaded all of them I'm
gonna be creating a package.json file
I'm gonna quickly copy and paste over
all of our dependencies so in our
dependencies we'll be stalling things
necessary for anger to run and our dev
dependencies we'll be using different
things for um web pack and we're using
the fittings for testing and again this
will come full circle throughout the
entirety of this video so we have all
those things in there and without any
further ado let's install them all so
I'm gonna bring the terminal up here and
I'm gonna run npm install okay so now
while that's installing this is a great
time for us to talk about typescript so
if you don't know what typescript is
it's a superset of JavaScript and it's
built by Microsoft and the Anglin team
decided that they want angular to be
built with typescript and gives a whole
bunch of functionality to it and you can
get type safety and one thing we gotta
realize is that web pack being a modular
bundle only recognize J's files so to
use it throughout our application we
need to convert these files from
typescript down to JavaScript so to do
that we're gonna be creating a config
file that most TS owners understand and
will use okay so I'm gonna come in here
now I'll be creating a TS config file
OOP it's actually TS config dot JSON
sorry about that
okay and that's gonna quickly copy and
paste over some boilerplate
I'm configuration settings so real quick
we're gonna be converting our TS Co
because we're targeting job should be a
6-3 mckernon converting it down to es6
and we're gonna do a couple other things
I'm using common J's and all our modules
and node modular resolution is a common
way to do that have these lives here
awesome okay so next up if you may have
guessed it is that we also need a config
file for web pack to you
so I want to come in here when you
create a wet pack configure a JS file
I'm so quickly copy/paste this is gonna
do it's just gonna require a file that
we'll be creating later and our config
folder called web pack dev jazz awesome
so when we run a webpage web pack we'll
go to config file and run that file
awesome so next thing we will be
thinking about testing if we actually go
to our pack is a JSON file you will see
that we have the Jasmine assertion
library and we also have karma to run
our tests so again karma needs a
configuration file so let's create a
karma configuration file okay I'm just
gonna copy and paste over some other
things it's gonna just basically do what
we did in our web hack config file just
gonna require file that will create
later okay awesome so next thing up is
let's talk about web pack and how it
works so web pack builds a dependency
graph through it entry point for our
whole application it does this by
looking at import statements so it does
this and it puts all of our application
code into one big bundle okay so this
bundle if we want to add cool stuff to
it like for example what I love to use
in my application just hot module
reloading
if you don't know what how module load
is what it basically does is basically
insert script tags into your application
and then basically it updates your code
in real time so you don't need to
refresh the browser so it makes
developing a whole lot more fun so the
problem with that is we don't want to
keep reloading the code every time we
don't want to keep refreshing it and
things that are static we don't want to
keep refreshing them because again web
packet take a while to refresh things
that are big so for all of our static
assets we're going to put them into our
separate bundle so I'm gonna be creating
a quick vendor dot TS file in our vendo
TS file and ABI
copying and pasting over all of our
static stuff so here's just a bunch of
sack stuff you know things like angular
like the angular compiler and stuff like
that that won't change throughout our
application awesome okay so have all
that so next we're gonna create one more
bundle polyfills and again this is to
set up environments and compiler code to
be cross browser and cross platform
compatible okay there we go awesome and
so we also had this thing for processed
and ve NV which we'll be using for our
node E and V to set the environment for
our project which will be giving to
later and this stuff here just sets of
long air stack traces when we're running
in development mode ok awesome
okay guys so before we go in-depth on
our webpack configuration let's quickly
scaffold out in angular for application
so first things first we're going to
bootstrap angular by building or by
creating a main dot ts file I'm just
gonna copy later over some boilerplate
bootstrap configurations so here we go
and one thing to note here is we're
actually enabling the hot module
replacement that I alluded to earlier
right here okay so got that in there
awesome so next thing up is we're gonna
actually create a folder here I'm gonna
call it app okay so in our app folder
we'll be creating an app component dot
ES file and we'll also be creating at
module dot ES file okay so our module
basically hold our dependencies or our
app component file has access to so
let's come in here I'm just gonna
quickly um scaffold out the module oh
there it is okay so got that in there
and then just to add a couple things to
it we will be adding in our imports we
will be also adding the browser module
which is essential for angular to run
into browsers there we go
and also it's going to need access to
where our main component is so in a
components quickly scaffold out a
component awesome let's change some
names here let's change this to app
let's change this to F as well and we're
not using s CSS we're going to be using
CSS the words can change it from name to
app awesome so let's come here and
create those two files that we're
missing that HTML and then
CSS okay let's come in here let's just
put in an h1 tag and be like hello from
the starter okay gotcha
so got that in there so go back to
abdominal let's declare it
oops excuse me let's declare in our
declarations and let's also bootstrap it
so we're gonna add bootstrap right here
OOP if I could spell it correctly and
we're gonna put it in our app component
so it knows our main component to do it
to when we quickly changed this from
feature to app module okay there we go
now we quickly scaffold out our angular
for application
so now we're going to dive more in depth
on our web pad configuration so a web
pet configuration file will have three
different environments a development
environment production environment and a
testing environment okay so with all
these three environments there is
definitely a lot of common things
associated between all three so we're
gonna first start off by building a web
pack common configuration file so when I
come in here when I come to our config
and we're going to be creating a web
pack that common J's file and so I'm
just gonna quickly copy over some of
these will be using webpack our HTML web
pack plug-in which this will actually
insert dynamically insert a script tag
to our bundle so we don't need to do
that for us in our index.html file I'm
gonna extract text plug-in which
basically takes all our CSS and listen
to a different bundle so when we load
our application we could load our
JavaScript and CSS in parallel so things
are a lot a lot faster and our helpers
file here which is just gives us access
to a root function we'll be using to set
up pass within our web pack config file
so coming back to the web pack column
let's come here and let's do module
export okay the first things first we
need to create the entry where our web
pack will be creating our dependency
graph I look at those import statements
so we're gonna have three entries we're
gonna be entering from polyfills vendor
and we're gonna be entering through our
angular application and that's gonna be
source slash main okay so now that we
have all that in there we've set up our
three bundles so next thing up we're
going to create a resolve okay and we're
gonna resolve on extensions okay so
whenever web pack looks at a files in
the first try resolve it as either a
type your file or a JavaScript file so
that's why I didn't have to include it
up here okay so next up we're gonna be
going into modules so in the module we
will be having rules and rules is how we
set up loaders so remember how I said
earlier that we need to compile our
typescript files into J's files this is
where I'll be setting up the logic do
that right here so first things first
we're gonna be testing for where's
backslash there it is dot TS so we're
gonna be testing for everything with a
dot TS extension and if we find it we're
going to be so webpack wheezy's loaders
and d and a ascending order so it reads
it from bottom to top so again this is
gonna be the last lor that's gonna run
is going to be the babel loader okay and
after that we will be running
the awesome typescript loader so this
loader will actually convert our type
script into our es6 target that we put
on our TS config file and then in
options we're just going to tell it to
the config file name will be when use
our helpers function
okay so there we go and then last but
not least we'll be having one more
loader attached to this so we will also
have our
angular2 template loader so the angular
2 template loader to talk about all
three and what's going on here the
Inglot template loader will inline all
of our templates and styles that are on
our components just to give you the
visual example right here all these will
be inlined
and we need this for building a OT build
which I'll get into later so first it
does that and then next the awesome type
script loader takes it from type script
looks at our TS config file which we
tell where to find it and it loads it
into vs6 code then we'll have a babel
loader do it next and i'll get into a
second why we have our babel loader so
it's from bot on the top is how the
loaders work okay so after we have all
those loaders run the last thing we're
going to do is exclude some files
there's just some files that we don't
care about running through our TS loader
and that's gonna be our node modules
okay
awesome so we did that so let's come
down here and let's add some more
loaders so I'm just gonna copy and paste
these right now to save some time so
we're going to the adding a JavaScript
loader so when we have JavaScript we're
gonna run through our babel loader and
we have our presets to es2015
so now this is something very cool that
i specifically used for my applications
so talking about browser compatibility
there's a bunch of different things a
bunch of different polyfills to worry
about you know why worry about any of
that why not just have something that
already has standards set do it for you
that's exactly what babel odor with the
presets es2015 does so first things
first we're gonna have to come over here
and create a babel config file which is
called Da'Ville RC o RX RC okay and then
in our babel RC file gonna put the copy
over some boilerplate configurations
okay so what's gonna be doing is gonna
be looking at different pi files that
are already associated with this type of
setup and it's going to use a latch to
version
of every browser and greater than or
equal to Safari of version 7 and we're
not gonna use load modules again use
again our TS config files are re loading
modules for this through commonjs
so we do that then we don't need to
worry about compatibility for browsers
so that's pretty cool saved us a lot of
time and a lot of headache of trying to
find the right polyfills ourselves so
we're gonna do that awesome
so the next loader we'll be doing is an
HTML loader and this will basically just
take our HTML and throw it through an
HTML loader which we're gonna clone into
strings then basically have it use as
JavaScript that our web head will be
able to recognize so after we do that
I'm gonna set up a loader real quick for
our images and different types of files
so our file loader will basically take
create pass well take all of our images
and load it make it compatible with our
bundle and give us access to them
through relative pass throughout our
application that we set up through web
pack awesome
and then another loader we'll be doing
is CSS
we will be having two loaders here so
not there right here okay
so first of all we're gonna do is put
CSS to raw loader which is loads of the
strings and then we're gonna be using
the extract text plug-in which I talked
about briefly earlier which takes all
our CSS of our app bundle and puts it in
a separate bundles for your loader in
parallel with our application okay
awesome so that about does it
for all of our loaders I think we pretty
much covered everything here again you
can do stuff for like a CSS for a pug
whatever you want to use but again this
is boilerplate stuff typical things I I
see and not use so we're gonna leave it
here okay so the next thing we're
getting to is plugins so a plugins are
basically just extra functionality we're
gonna add so that web packet add to our
application so first things first I'm
gonna had a context replacement plug-in
it's just gonna help alleviate some
warnings that might arise okay and then
after that I will be so
even though we gave three entry points
for our application wet peck isn't smart
enough to see those and be like oh I
need to split the Zonda three different
bundles doesn't know so we need to
actually have a plug in give webpack the
ability to recognize oh hey I need to
separate this into three different
bundles so we're gonna do that with not
that one Oh web pack a web pack
optimized we're gonna copy and paste it
my typing is subpar today alright so
we're gonna come here paste the common
chunks plug-in so this basically lets
web heck identify okay we need three
bundles to build okay next and we're
gonna just do the HTML web pack plug-in
which again I talked about earlier and
this will just dynamically insert the
script tag referencing our bundle into
index ID into index.html and if you
remember we didn't create an index at
HTML so let's created real quickly okay
and then let's just copy and paste some
things over I'm just gonna copy paste
some boilerplate things over okay
awesome so got that in there and got
reference to my app which if you
remember it was our app dot components
selectors you can see right there
awesome okay so there we go we have our
web pack common build-out
okay guys let's go and create our web
pack def config file but before we do
that let's fix a couple little mistakes
I made in the web pack common file I'm a
couple of typos um this is not polyfills
that's probably fill which is where I
named the file I changed out to probably
fill and then let's come up here and I
put it as rules it's actually plaus it
as rule let's put it as plural as rules
okay awesome
so now let's come in here and then let's
create our web page is file okay and I'm
just gonna copy over some stuff that's
gonna look very similar to our web pack
common configuration but you'll notice
that we have a web pack merge and a path
to our exported comma configuration so
let's start building it okay so I'm
gonna use the web pack merge on our
common configuration and we're gonna add
talking get some dev tools in there so
when use the cheap module eval source
and so basically what this is doing is
this is making it easier for us to debug
the big bundle that webpack creates for
us
then we're gonna create our L path
configuration so at the very least for a
web pack to work you need an entry file
and you need an output configuration so
let's set the path for it right now and
we're gonna set it as helpers root disk
and so this is where the bundles will be
you know export it to will be exported
to the disk folder when we set a public
path for all our assets as just slash
we're going to do some file naming
bundle jas and we're going to serve some
chunk file-naming
okay so now we have all that and we have
the bare minimum to run a web pack
application so let's go ahead and let's
run it so I'm going to bring my terminal
up here and if you haven't I have it to
gain access to WebEx CLI or you could
run it through the bin folder and your
know modules or you could run it through
a script in your pekka's out JSON but if
you want to run through a CLI just run
NPM install with a peg - G draw globally
I already did this so I'm not gonna do
it again and so once you've installed it
just run the command web pack oh I must
have spelled it wrong sorry about that
guys common config okay and then let's
grab it back out here okay so here we go
it's bundling and there we go so as you
can see we have a three bundles here the
pile is that bottle ijs the app on logis
and oh we have two Poli we have a
polyfills and a polyfill bundles ijs
probably because if we have to change
something in the kama configuration
let's go fix that now it's going to the
common configuration like Phil Phil oh
we got to change this to polyfill there
we go okay and let's run it one more
time
okay there we go so there we go we have
our three bundles right here okay and as
you can see we attracted our vendor
bundle and again I was talking about
stack assets and look that's three
megabytes so you don't need a recompile
every time we make changes to our code
okay awesome so there you go you can see
it bundled and then if we look into our
folder structure you will also see that
a disc file has been created and within
our disk file is all the assets that we
exported there and then within our app
bottle digest
you will see kind of what it looks like
sort of look this is what on the module
bundles look like this how this jumbled
up you know mess and then it connects to
all these different things here okay so
now let's go back to our deck
configuration let's confits a finished
configure eight configuring it so after
the output here the next thing we're
gonna do is and give it a dev server so
out of the box what pack provides us
with the web pack dev server they became
used to run our application so we're
gonna quickly configure it right here
and we're going to set the history
to true and this lets us use html5
pushstate instead of the hashed location
strategy and we're gonna set the stats
as minimal now okay
so I got that there so then next up is
plugins so these are plugins that are
specific to the dev environment so it's
gonna copy over a couple of things okay
and then just copy over one more thing
okay okay so the name modulus plug-in is
what we're gonna be using to help with
our hot module replacement on the web
pack define plug-in defines global
variables for us throughout our
application in this case if we were
using an API on localhost 5,000 this is
how you would quickly set up the way to
use this throughout your hob Acacia make
it really easy to switch where your API
calls are hitting when you're changing
environments and the extract text
plug-in again just basically is giving
it the name of the CSS then it's
abstracting from our app daibo notch is
awesome
okay so there's our web pack dev
configuration finished so now let's move
on to our web pack production
configuration so I'm gonna come in here
and I'm going to create a new another
file called WebEx projects okay so in
the prodigious we're gonna have again a
very similar configuration but we're
gonna now start setting up environments
so before we even get too far into this
let's start setting up the environments
that we're going to need for this
application so we're gonna do that in
the package that JSON so the type of
that JSON we have access to these
scripts here and through these scripts
we could set different environments
through node okay so let's set a couple
right now so first one I'm gonna set is
going to be I'm just going to add some
configuration actually to the list right
here so it's already configured
correctly just these are configuration
these and
- hot enables hot module replacement for
our deaf server okay so first thing I do
is create a wet peg dev and it's gonna
run cross E and V which is a way to set
the note environment variable on Windows
and other cross platforms node E and V
equals development and then we run wet
pack okay and then we're gonna basically
have a wet pack prod which is just gonna
run across V and V node E and V Eagles
production and then we're also gonna run
one pack after that as well okay so
there we go we set up our environments
here awesome so now we're gonna come
back into our WebP a config file really
a config file hold on I gotta readjust
this there it is okay so when we come
back into our web pack and fig file and
we're gonna change out how this is Ron
so now that we have set environment
variables we're coming here and we're
gonna go by room
so when you set the no D&V in the
package.json this is where it's stored
I'm gonna see was equal to the
development and trimly or the white
space okay so if
so if environment equals development
we're going to use the dev environment
and if not we're going to be using the
production environment
okay awesome okay so now that we have
the environment set up let's go back
into our web pack production okay and
then we're going to quickly set up the
configuration with what pack merge and
basically the same thing we did and what
pack dev with the comic is big so in dev
tools we're just gonna use source map
instead of the cheap avail source map
and for output we're going to be
changing a lot about the outputs we're
going to still be not actually not
changing anything about the output sorry
that misleads you folks we're going to
use the same output configuration that
we use for dev and then plugins will be
a little bit different so plugins that
will be specific to a production
environment things we want to do is we
would want to do like I'm gonna pick
that no Amit
we want to know millionaires plug in for
the production code so don't want that
crashing we would also want to uglify
our code and compress it down to make
our module bundle even smaller so we're
gonna do that by using the uglify JS
plugin which will basically minify and
compress no just yeah well of the fire
our code sorry about that and then after
we do that we will be using the extract
text plug-in which again will load our
CSS in parallel to make it even faster
and then we will also just to show you
guys we will also have a workaround
right here okay so there we go there's
our production environment setup awesome
and so now I'm just gonna quickly um
just to make sure everything's working
I'm gonna put in here fraud okay so now
let's run web practice duction through
our terminal
we're on NPM run web pack pry we were
gonna just about that wrong
oh man I butchered that one all right
there we go come back in here and let's
run it so you see now we're running in
the prod folder it takes a second to
compile because again we are also Uggla
fiying it during the build process
okay and there we go as you can see our
our bundle sizes are significantly
smaller than they were previously and
this is very helpful for building very
high speed applications okay so we have
that done and that completes our
production setup
okay guys now that we have built both
our production and our development wet
pad configuration files I think it's
time to just run the app and take a look
at what it looks like so before we move
on to our test environment let's do that
we're going to come into our package dot
JSON as you can see we already have the
web pack start configuration I have a
bunch of config these on arrow with how
about you reload have the progress open
in the default browser on port 8080
awesome alright so then let's open up
our terminal and then let's quickly
navigate to it and then let's run npm
run start as you can see it opens up
right here floating oh we got an error
evany did not match any element oh okay
so unfortunately the joys of live coding
does have some pitfalls it looks like I
did miss some naming up so if we go to
our index.html I named it my app which I
believe in our app dot component it's
actually app name so let's go back to
index.html change it to app name
okay there we go awesome
so now let's navigate back to our
terminal close it and rerun it as you
can see it's loaded again we wait for it
to finish let's put this over here if we
get split screen view let's open this up
and as you can see boom we have the
hello from the angular starter alright
and as you can also see in our console
here we can see we're in development
mode and we also have hot module
replacement enabled so I know I talked
about hot module replacement before but
let me really show you what it does so
if I come here and I just add in let's
say hot module replacement rules and I
click right when I click outside of
focus it reloads when I click and lose
focus and the application saves in my
Visual Studio code IDE automatically
updates without any refresh so this
makes senior output extremely fast and
just like makes development so much of
more enjoyable alright so now it's time
to move on to the test environment let's
get started
okay guys now that we have created our
webpack production environment we need
to create a web pack testing environment
so let's get started
so because I kind of talked about
earlier we had to create that karma
config file and we were gonna build on
that later so we're gonna start right
now so on the config on the create
another karma config file okay and in
here I'm just gonna quickly pay some
boilerplate code and go over it real
quickly so basically what this is gonna
do is it's gonna import our web pack
test file which we're gonna create in
just a second
I think you'd be using jasmine here's
the files and the panics gonna be
looking for pre-processors right here is
gonna be a karma test shim which we're
gonna create real quickly and this is
just to give it browser compatibility
shim yes oh excuse me
karma - m - j @o desu wow I'm all over
the place here Howard test - shim dot J
s okay and then in here I'm just gonna
paste a whole bunch of stuff that we'll
be using as shims OOP not that okay and
just a whole bunch of things we will be
using
okay so then back in here I'm in our web
peg middleware stance there's only with
X server no info okay
then in a reporter's when we using
progress to report our test and if we've
already got poor 9 8 7 6 so now we have
our configuration files set up let's go
ahead and let's actually add a test so
we're just gonna add one test and the
test is just gonna be testing to see if
the tests are actually working so we're
gonna come in here we're going to create
an app component dots back dot ES file
then in here I'm gonna basically copy
and paste what our tests are gonna be
doing and it's basically just going to
be creating the configuration for the
test environment for our angular
application and we just be testing if
it's working okay so that we have all
that there let's run our test if we
remember in our package that JSON we had
an NPM run test
of command run that oh I've got
something wrong up
did I forget the name of something let's
take a look real quickly sorry about
that guys
oh I forgot to add the webpack test so
let's add it real quickly so webpack die
test digest is getting ahead of myself
there sorry about that so in the whip
egg that I'm just gonna copy and paste
it so I'm specially gonna look a lot
like other two files not much of a
difference here I'm just basically to
set the test environment of how to
basically compile our you know our Tiger
code and everything else okay so now we
have that let's run our test one more
time yeah okay so while we're waiting
should open up a browser any second now
once it compiles there we go we got it
in the test pass so there we go we have
set up our testing environment that can
easily be expanded for anything
throughout our whole application awesome
okay guys for the final part of our
project setup we'll be sending our
angular application to use the ahead of
time compiler now as of right now it's
using the just-in-time compiler which
compiles the code for every instance of
the application running which could slow
down the performance of our application
and we don't want that we want our app
running at blazing fast speed so there's
a couple little tweaks for you to do
this stuff the angler our angular
application wrong with ahead of time
compiler so let's dive right in so first
things first I want to show you this
list of Engler don'ts while building the
building with the äôt compiler so as you
can see right here we have a couple of
them most importantly the ones that we
will need is we don't use require status
for your temperature styles we have the
used style URLs and temple URLs and
that's where the angular 2 template load
of plug-in that we already loaded in our
pegs adjacent will help us out with a
couple of things with forms don't use
default exports use public for any
annotations and yeah ok so now let's get
started let's start building it so first
things first
hangar äôt uses a different type of
typescript compiler for this so we will
need to be giving it a different types
or a compiler configuration so when I
come in here and install a TS config
that's a ot that JSON file and so I'm
just gonna come here I'm gonna copy and
paste the code we're gonna be using for
this and go over it so again we'll be
targeting es6 not too much just changed
here these are juicy difference we don't
have this anger compile options thing
here which will be running through the
general directive äôt folder which is
going to be generated when we run the
angular typescript äôt compiler and
we're gonna step here's the entry module
we'll be using
so as you can see the file we'll be
looking for is may not a OT that TS this
is because the made a ott s is
bootstrapping
at module factory instead of may not see
s which is bootstrapping at module so
let's create our main dot a
ts file so we're gonna come here we do
main dot io TTS there we go then I was
gonna quickly copy over this stuff we
gotta use for that okay so there we go
and so just again the big changes we're
using at module Factory instead of at
module another thing you can see is
online safes for enabling proud mode so
now if we're running the maintenance we
know that we're using running the
application through production mode and
when angular runs in development runs
development ro excuse me well words all
jumbled up when angular runs in
development mode it runs actually two
checks on it to see if any expression
change after it was checked errors occur
and these are take a little bit more
time to run through the compiled through
the change detection through angular so
running enable prom mode actually speeds
up your application a whole bunch
because it eliminates that second check
so it'll be enabling prime mode right
there okay awesome so now we have to
come into our web pack common config and
we need to change a few things for our
environment so we're come in here so in
our app so first things first I'm going
to define something right here
we're gonna define a variable and we use
we're going to do it is prod variable so
you look at process that E&V know D and
V and it's going to check if it equals
to production so it's gonna see if its
production or not so I want to come down
here I'm gonna be like we use a ternary
operator so it is prod we're gonna run
okay so if it is proud we're going to be
running the manor
that TS file if it's not probably going
to be running the main file okay who
made that TS sorry okay what so now
we're going to come down here and we're
also gonna have to know I think that's
pretty much all we need is to just
change your bootstrapping the files from
so but now we also need to come into our
package that JSON and so have some
scripts to run the äôt typescript
compiler and configure the build so
let's add them real quickly so first
things first we're gonna have to have a
build for it so I'm gonna call build a
ot and build a ot is gonna run the ng C
compiler which is the head of time
compiler in production and we're gonna
run it with TS config - a ot JSON okay
and then we're also gonna have a build a
ot prod which will run npm run build a
ot and it will also run npm run web pack
prod okay
OOP and let's fix this right here okay
there we go so we got all that in there
so now that we have that in there let's
run our IOT build so let's pull up the
terminal and let's clear it out real
quickly
now it's from NPM build you know what I
call build - a ot - price run that
I spelled build wrong some of the guys
fraud there you go okay so now we see
wearing the ng C compiler and as you can
see now an AO t file has just appeared
and that's gonna contain all of our a ot
folders in here awesome and then now we
could see that we're also running on the
web pack production config file so it's
basically going to take that put that
into the disk folder so we're gonna
weigh on that to compile okay and there
we go and this is our ahead of time
compile or build so now everything will
be available within our disk for so then
all you have to do is point whatever
server you're using to run the comments
when this disk folder then you'll be
running ahead of time compiled angular
for application all right so thank you
guys so much for watching I've been
wanting to this video for a while
learning how to do this myself I mean
took you know like a like a little bit
over a year I want to learn it just kind
of doing on my own looking for
information I'm happy to help and I
really just don't want to see people
suffering from the same pitfalls I had
trying to learn you know kind of what
everything does and how to do this so um
thanks again for watching and yeah take
care